dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here a quick
recap for the fellow scholars out there
who missed some of our earlier episodes
the neural network is a machine learning
technique that was inspired by the human
brain it is not a brain simulation by
any stretch of the imagination
but it was inspired by the inner
workings of the human brain we can train
it on input and output pairs like images
and descriptions whether the images
depict a mug or a bus the goal is that
after training we would give unknown
images to the network and expect it to
recognize whether there is a mug or a
bus on them it may happen that during
training it seems that the neural
network is doing quite well but when we
provide the unknown images it falters
and almost never gets the answer right
this is the problem of overfitting and
intuitively it is a bit like students
who are not preparing for an exam by
obtaining useful knowledge but students
who prepare by memorizing answers from
the textbook instead no wonder their
results will be rubbish on a real exam
but no worries because we have dropout
which is a spectacular way of creating
diligent students this is a technique
where we create a network where each of
the neurons have a chance to be
activated or disabled a network that is
filled with unreliable units and I
really want you to think about this if
we could have a system with perfectly
reliable units we should probably never
go for one that is built from less
reliable units instead what is even more
this piece of work proposes that we
should [ __ ] our systems and seemingly
make them worse on purpose this sounds
like a travesty why would anyone want to
try anything like this and what is
really amazing is that these unreliable
units can potentially build a much more
useful system that is less prone to
overfitting if we want to win
competitions we have to train many
models and average them as we have seen
with the Netflix prize winning algorithm
in an earlier episode it also relates
back to the Committee of doctors example
that is usually more useful than just
asking one doctor and the absolutely
amazing thing is that this is
what robot gives us it gives the average
of a very large number of possible
neural networks and we only have to
train one network that we crippled here
and there to obtain that this procedure
with our dropout would normally take
years and such exorbitant time frames to
compute and would also raise all kinds
of pesky problems we really don't want
to deal with to engage in modesty let's
say that if we are struggling with
overfitting we could do a lot worse than
using dropout it indeed teaches slacking
students how to do their homework
properly please keep in mind that using
dropout also leads to longer training
times my experience has been between 2
to 10x but of course it heavily depends
on other external factors so it is
indeed true that dropout is slow
compared to training 1 Network but it is
blazing fast at what it actually
approximates which is training an
exponential number of models
I think dropout is one of the greatest
examples of the beauty and the perils of
research where sometimes the most
counterintuitive ideas give us the best
results thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time